someone tweeted this earlier it's from
August 12th 2021 from the United States
Attorney's Office Southern District of
Texas young soldiers admit to
transporting undocumented citizens my
stars and GS you mean if you transport
non-citizens you are breaking the law I
got questions for the Biden
Administration but more importantly let
me say this as clearly as I can to each
and every one of you border patrol
officers and law enforcement officials
for the federal government who are
taking orders from hups telling you to
transport non-citizens illegal
immigrants to all those crew of Swift
air private Airlines I will not forget
nor will anyone who's watched this show
nor will any politician we petition we
will never forget that under our laws
you are committing crimes and you think
simply because it's ubiquitous you will
get away with it I assure you you will
not if you wear a badge and you are
instructed to break the law and you
break the law we will not forget
this is from justice.gov
2021 two military men Station at Fort
Hood have entered guilty pleas to
conspiring to transport undocumented
aliens within the United States
announced acting us Attorney Jennifer B
Lowry now how is it that three years ago
two and a half years ago it is a
criminal offense to plead guilty to if
you're transporting undocumented aliens
in this country but now how many law
enforcement officials government
contractors and all you employees of
Swift air are doing just this without a
care in the world I hope I beg and I
pray that when Donald Trump is elected
he arrests each and every one of you
because you are breaking the law and
simply because you all did it with your
friends doesn't mean you get away with
it when I saw this I was
pissed I have no problem with any of the
quote unquote destruction that Donald
Trump is talking about and in fact I
don't think that Donald Trump will go
far enough if he actually does get
elected people forget even Obama when he
was presid deported hundreds of
thousands if not millions of legal
immigrants Obama himself enforced that
law he was the deporter and chief the
phenomena we're seeing now with Joe
Biden with the poorest border and and
taking the dollars that taxpayers give
to the border security to use it to
bring them in this is actually a new
phenomena even for Democrats even for
Obama and you can you say I oppose this
they say you hate you hate they attack
you you hate this you hate that but
Obama did it yeah cuz he used to
understand that if you have taxes you're
asking for like taxes from a tax base
you have to have a close system you
can't just open up to the world and then
give it to everybody you can't there's
no way you're going to be able to fo
that bill it's ridiculous there was a
CBP guy who pulled up in his truck to
the Razer wire in Texas and saw illegal
immigrants trying to enter and he said
turn around now he's under investigation
they're putting they're getting him in
trouble for it he's doing his job he's
enforcing the law that's a good man and
the Biden Administration expects you to
break the law but I just I just I'm GNA
read this for you they say these men
face up to 10 years in prison and a
possible $250,000 maximum fine when I
was in Chicago over Christmas we had a
shuttle driver bringing us to our uh we
are connecting to what do we fly back on
we flew on
um American maybe I can't remember and
uh this shuttle bus driver said that he
they they also did uh uh they serviced
private planes they Jets so they got
worried the Blackhawks were coming
Chicago Blackhawks o big hockey fans and
the 737 pulls up full of passengers they
pull their car up open the the the
forward cargo uh on the belly of the
plane three garbage bags and they were
like what is this and they load the
garbage bags onto their car and they
were like they shrug and then they found
out the plane was transporting illegal
immigrants into Chicago I asked him I
was like they he said they lied to us
they told us it was the Blackhawks and I
said did they lie to you because you
would not have served illegal immigrants
had you known that's what they asked you
to do and he goes yep so the only way to
get these crew members to actually to
facilitate these planes is to trick them
into doing it cuz that's a good guy he
was telling me I would not have done
that if they didn't trick me I say you
sir are a victim they tricked you but
all these guys they know what they're
doing and I'm I'm just I I I beg and I
pray man I want Donald Trump to get in I
don't think he'll do it because it's
it's important to point out Trump is not
a dictator he never was and he won't
Trump's going to go in there and he's
going to say look we love our men and
women in uniform we're not going to hold
it against them we're going to go for
the leadership I get so many
conservatives in here being like I'm not
going to blame the police for what they
did I'm going to blame the higher-ups
and I'm like oh no if it were me I'd go
to each and every every individual and I
would say sir you can put on the chains
on your ankles right now I'll put you in
the jumpsuit you committed this crime I
don't care if if a vision came to you in
your sleep of a prophet telling you to
commit the crime I don't care if your
mother told you to do it I don't care if
Joe Biden told you to do it you broke
the law you broke the law if Joe Biden
says go rob a bank you you rob the bank
but these people I'm I'm I'm worried
they'll get away with it and then this
is what happens we supposed to forget 10
years from now we'll just forget that
this happened I hope
not all right it's been a good show
everybody that's I mean what do you do
when the President says to do something
like that I mean is that look I'll give
I'll give it the big ask I don't expect
Donald Trump to start locking up all of
our law enfor we need law enforcement
but these people should have a reckoning
of some sort I think they should get
their pensions stripped from them or
something like that what'll really end
up happening is I will say something
like Donald Trump must arrest anyone who
committed committed these crimes and
then Trump will say well we're not going
to do that too far but we will do and
then we'll get something out of it the
scary thing is what if what if like I
mean his entire first you know first
term the first for the whole four years
the FBI or at least half the FBI was
working actively working against him
subverting the president
like it's legitimate to fire all those
people and the idea that it's not
legitimate to fire the people that are
wor like we should charge those people
we should investigate look for the
people that were actually trying to
subvert the directives of the
commander-in-chief the fed you know the
director of the of the justice
department is you know the president's
the executive he's in charge of the
whole thing human smuggling that's what
the justice.gov website calls it human
smuggling there there's been a uh I
guess even among some of the least
likely to fight colleagues in mind that
are Republicans a push lately to not
fund anything unless we get border
enforcement and enforce our immigration
laws because it is you know that obvious
to the American people even some
Democrats have been breaking we've had a
few votes where on the spending bills we
said this is contingent upon uh
enforcing immigration laws which is
clearly not happening and some Democrats
have started vote with us on this so I I
you know I you know I hear what Tim
saying obviously very passionate
American people see that too but it
isn't just President Biden frankly the
the voters gave us a republican House of
Representatives which has the power of
the purse and we fund this with your tax
dollars we don't have story un to do
that yeah this is a story that we
covered quite a bit we showed this to
Marion Williamson October 20th 2021 more
migrant children being flown to New York
but what happens to them after they
arrive you know I hope that when Donald
Trump gets
elected his attorney general will order
an investigation who will find the
pilots of these planes and put them in
prison for 10 years and I hope the
pilots of these planes hear what I'm
saying right now and I hope you know
every opportunity I get to speak to
people who are seeking these
positions when they when I see them
whoever it may turn out to be I will be
saying to them when you are in the White
house I want to see the people who flew
these planes in shackles I want to see
them crying on television after a per
walk saying I'm so sorry I was
trafficking children into this country
illegally they think because they work
for a corporation they're shielded I
want all of those people to know I will
do everything in my power to Advocate
you spend your life Behind
Bars I'm so sick of the banality of evil
of people who work for these companies
who facilitate crimes and think because
Joe Biden is President and because the
president is corrupt you will get away
with it you're not just doing your job
you're breaking the law and we're going
to enforce the law the way the law was
written I'm just sick of it man it's
it's plain as day right in front of us
we've covered these stories so many
times there was uh who was it there was
some some reps from out of Tennessee the
Biden Administration was taking illegal
immigrants from the border putting them
on planes and flying them at 2 in the
morning to
Tennessee well if if that's a crime that
that two men were pleading guilty to to
moving transporting undocumented aliens
the bid Administration is ordering
people to do it that's too bad for you
guys you're the one I we got to lock
them up lock them all up there should be
massive massive investigations massive
amounts of Investigations I the you
could I truly believe that you can just
have the FBI investigate the federal
government and they'd be busy for a
decade they' probably never get done
because as they investigate there's
going to be more
the Federal Bureau of Investigation now
means investigating the federal bureaus
right or we could just get rid of them I
mean look if you want to get rid of you
know cabinet level bureaucracies
everyone that watches the show a lot
knows how I feel about that get them out
of there fire people
unemployment but we never cut it's the
bity of evil man it's these it's the
people who sell their souls to the devil
people will say well you know what I'm
going to do it anyway yeah can't we
can't live that way but not only that
that the it's I mean part of this does
fall on and it doesn't fall on to the
the the viewers of the show but part of
it does fall on to the people of America
because people don't know anything about
the way that our government works so
they can't even know what they should be
voting for or what you know what what
makes sense for them to be voting for
and I mean I personally feel like people
look at voting like praying it's like oh
if I go over there and I I vote for this
thing then you know hopefully I'll get
it but voting never turns out that way
we got a Super Chat kako says I'm a
major US airline pilot and was Furious
when I found out we had illegals on our
flights I hear you but they don't tell
us good sir I am not speaking of you you
I believe are a good man if you're an
airline pilot and they tell you routine
flight have a good day and you are not
party to what's going on then I think
the simple thing is we look at the
flight manifests I think law enforcement
should ask ask what happened tell us
what happened you say I'm just an
airline I had no idea what's going on
and we say all right man thank you so
much for helping assist and figuring out
who was facilitating this stuff and
that's it end of story and then I'm
specifically referring to there are
private
Airlines so I don't uh uh the guy told
me in Chicago it was Swift air and a lot
of people have said it's Swift air I
don't know if if that's true it it's you
know whatever but uh that's what the guy
said yeah there's no way a Private Pilot
doesn't know what he's doing when the P
the plane is loaded up with nothing but
illegal immigrants all carrying those
little baggies or whatever yeah you can
be like guy I'm not flying This Plane
are you nuts that's illegal I I I I you
know I I just I just pulled up here from
justice.gov let me just make sure it's
very very clear to each and every one of
you because we got at least one airline
pilot here if you transport undocumented
aliens you can go to prison for up to 10
years so if you are sitting in that
pilot seat and you see them boarding
your plane and they don't have tickets
with names on them because that's
already been what's reported oh boyy if
you think you're not going to get in
trouble for that I got a bridge to sell
you you're you're going to have to get
off and be like I'm not flying a plane
with people who who don't have tickets
this is illegal that's pretty insane do
they go through security and all that
stuff it's hard not to get on the plane
in the first place they had the tickets
had no name given and they're all
carrying these packets and there are
people now if you're a gate agent I I'm
sorry dude I worked for American Eagle
Airlines which is American Airlines
Regional I loaded planes
did not work gate gate people are the
they take your tickets and they scan
them if someone walks up to you with a
ticket and there's no name on it you
should be like I'm sorry sir you can't
get on this I know you could do that
right you can't James O'Keefe tries to
fly and he's got four s's on his ticket
and he gets pulled aside for a random
screening but these illegal immigrants
are being trafficked and they have
tickets with no names on them and the
gate agents are like what do I care I'm
getting paid baby well I hope you get
locked up too now and look I got look
I'm sorry I'm going to say this to the
pilot you find out after the fact you're
on a plane with with illegal immigrants
and you didn't know I can respect you
did not know I I'm I'm not trying to be
unreasonable the gate agents know for a
fact the gate agents have to let them
through yeah all of them should go to
jail what if you find out afterwards
that's like knowledge of a crime after
the fact right is do you you have to
report that to
somebody uh I don't know that you go to
jail because you may have witnessed a
crime you're unsure of and didn't report
it I mean that' be that'd be crazy like
you see a guy leaving a bank with a
burlap bag or whatever and you're like
well it's none of my business and they
like you should have reported you're
going to jail and no come on like you
don't you don't know what's going on so
I'm not going to blame in this instance
like a pilot who's sitting in his chair
ready to take off and he gets like you
have this x- money passengers and he
goes you got it and then later on
they're like there were illegal
immigrants there go like I had no idea I
can respect that gate agents all know
though illegal illegal immigrant walks
up with their packet and their and their
ticket obvious this is this is this is
crazy you and I both know that gate
agents are frequently uh entirely
disinterested in what's going on around
them I mean they're they're not they're
not particularly you know they're not
really paying attention they're kind of
just moving people through like they
they don't their jobs even if they did
report it they reported to the person
they're reporting to was the person
saying to do it anyway I mean they
should report it but the person they're
going to they're going to ignore it but
at least they'll be on record they
report it you think you could go to TSA
and be like hey you know TSA blah blah
blah in TSA apparently would be like oh
that's fine with us someone someone
chatted Tim fell off the fence but I got
to tell you guys if the sides of the
fence are we enforce our laws or we
don't yeah we got big we got big
problems it is the the the fact that we
have laws that we do and do not enforce
that's a massive problem like if you
don't know what to expect from the
government that puts everybody in a
position where they're constantly
anxious about what the government is
going to do and also that's part of how
it was possible for authoritarian
regimes yeah I was waiting for it to
come back to that yeah exactly to to
start turning to start turning family
members in and that's again that's
that's what it was it wasn't just every
lies to each other because no one
actually knows what the truth is anymore
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net